pero 1988 fue peor, con 440 muertes.
¿Qué está ocurriendo?
¿Es que 1988 fue un año especialmente malo?
¿O es que estas mejoras son una señal de que el mundo, con todas sus luchas,
está mejorando con el tiempo?
También podríamos invocar la sin duda anticuada noción de.. ¿progreso?
Hacerlo es exponerse a una cierta cantidad de burla,
porque he descubierto que los intelectuales odian el progreso.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y los intelectuales que se llaman progresistas realmente odian el progreso.
(Risas)
Ahora bien, la verdad, no es que ellos odien el fruto del progreso.
La mayoría de los académicos y de los expertos
preferirían someterse a cirugía con anestesia que sin ella.
Es la idea del progreso lo que irrita a los intelectualoides.
Me han dicho que creer que los humanos pueden mejorar su situación,
significa que uno tiene una fe ciega
y una creencia casi religiosa en la superstición pasada de moda
y en la falsa promesa del mito de la marcha hacia adelante
del progreso inexorable.
Uno es un animador del vulgar "todo se puede" de EE.UU.,
con el espíritu entusiasmado de la ideología de las salas de juntas,
Silicon Valley y la Cámara de Comercio.
Uno es un practicante de la "historia whig",
un optimista naif, un Pollyana, y, por supuesto, un Pangloss,
aludiendo al personaje de Voltaire que declaró:
"Todo sucede para bien en este, el mejor de los mundos posibles".
Bien, el profesor Pangloss era, en realidad, un pesimista.
Un verdadero optimista cree que puede haber mundos mejores
que este que tenemos ahora.
Pero todo esto es irrelevante,
porque la pregunta de si ha habido progreso
no es cuestión de fe
o de tener un temperamento optimista o de ver el vaso medio lleno.
Es una hipótesis comprobable.
Por todas sus diferencias,
la gente generalmente está de acuerdo en lo que constituye el bienestar humano:
vida, salud, sustento, prosperidad, paz, libertad, seguridad, conocimiento,
ocio, felicidad.
Todas estas cosas se pueden medir.
Si mejoraron con el paso del tiempo, yo sostengo que eso es progreso.
Pasemos a los datos,
comenzando por el más valioso de todos: la vida.
Durante casi toda la historia humana, la esperanza de vida al nacer eran 30 años.
Hoy en día, mundialmente, es de más de 70 años,
y en el mundo desarrollado
es de más de 80 años.
Hace 250 años, en los países más ricos del mundo,
un tercio de los niños no vivían para ver su quinto cumpleaños,
antes de que el riesgo descendiera 100 veces.
Hoy en día, menos de un 6 % de los niños corren esa misma suerte
en los países más pobres del mundo.
La hambruna es uno de los cuatro jinetes del Apocalipsis.
Puede llevar la devastación a cualquier parte del mundo.
Hoy, la hambruna ha sido desterrada
a las regiones más remotas y devastadas por la guerra.
Hace 200 años, un 90 % de la población mundial
subsistía en extrema pobreza.
Hoy en día, menos del 10 % de la gente lo hace.
En casi toda la historia humana,
los estados poderosos y los imperios
estuvieron casi siempre en guerra entre sí,
y la paz fue simplemente un interludio entre las guerras.
Hoy en día, nunca están en guerra entre sí.
La última gran guerra de poder
enfrentó a EE.UU. contra China hace 65 años.
Más recientemente, guerras de toda clase han disminuido y son menos mortales.
La tasa anual de guerras disminuyó de un 22 por cada 100 000 al año,
al principio de la década del 50, a 1,2 por cada 100 000, hoy en día.
La democracia ha sufrido, sin duda, retrocesos
en Venezuela, Rusia, Turquía
y está amenazada por el aumento del populismo autoritario
en el este de Europa y en EE.UU.
Sin embargo, el mundo nunca ha sido más democrático
que en la década pasada,
con dos tercios de la población mundial viviendo en democracias.
Las tasas de homicidio caen siempre que la anarquía y el código de venganza
son reemplazados por el estado de derecho.
Ocurrió cuando la Europa feudal fue puesta bajo el control de reinos centralizados,
por lo que, hoy en día, un europeo
tiene una posibilidad de ser asesinado de 1 en 35
comparado con sus ancestros medievales.
Ocurrió nuevamente en la Nueva Inglaterra colonial,
en el Salvaje Oeste de EE.UU., cuando los sheriffs se mudaron a la ciudad
y en México.
Verdaderamente, nos volvimos más seguros en todos los modos posibles.
Durante el último siglo, alcanzamos un 96 % menos de probabilidad
de morir en un accidente de auto,
un 88 % menos de posibilidad de ser abatidos en la acera,
un 99 % menos posibilidad de morir en un accidente de avión,
un 95 % menos de posibilidad de morir en el trabajo,
un 89 % menos de posibilidad de morir por un desastre natural,
como una sequía, inundación, incendio forestal, tormenta, volcán,
deslizamiento de tierra, terremoto o meteorito,
presumiblemente no porque Dios esté menos enojado con nosotros
sino por las mejoras en la resistencia de nuestra infraestructura.
¿Y qué sobre el desastre natural supremo
el proyectil lanzado por el mismo Zeus?
Sí, tenemos un 97 % menos de posibilidad de que nos mate un rayo.
Antes de siglo XVII,
solo un 15 % de los europeos sabían leer o escribir.
Europa y EE.UU. alcanzaron la alfabetización universal
a mediados del siglo XX,
y el resto del mundo la está alcanzando.
Hoy en día, más del 90 % de la población mundial
de menos de 25 años sabe leer y escribir.
En el siglo XIX, los occidentales trabajaban más de 60 horas por semana.
Hoy en día, trabajan menos de 40 horas.
Gracias al suministro universal de agua corriente y electricidad
en el mundo desarrollado
y la adopción general de lavarropas, aspiradoras,
refrigeradores, lavavajillas, hornos y microondas,
la cantidad de tiempo que pasamos en tareas domésticas
se redujo de 60 horas por semana
a menos de 15 horas por semana.
Todos estos avances en salud, riqueza, seguridad, conocimiento y ocio,
¿nos hacen más felices?
La respuesta es sí.
En un 86 % de los países del mundo,
la felicidad ha aumentado en las décadas recientes.
Bien, espero haberlos convencido
de que el progreso no es cuestión de fe u optimismo,
sino una realidad de la historia humana,
de hecho, la realidad más grande en la historia humana.
¿Y cómo han cubierto los medios esta realidad?
(Risas)
Una tabulación de palabras sobre emociones positivas y negativas en las noticias
mostró que durante las décadas en las que la humanidad se volvió más sana,
más rica, más sabia, más segura y más feliz,
"The New York Times" se volvió cada vez más sombrío
y las transmisiones de TV también se fueron volviendo más taciturnas.
¿Por qué la gente no aprecia el progreso?
Parte de la respuesta proviene de nuestra psicología cognitiva.
Estimamos los riesgos con un atajo mental: la "heurística de la disponibilidad".
Cuanto más fácil es evocar un recuerdo,
más lo consideramos como probable.
La otra parte de la respuesta proviene de la naturaleza del periodismo,
capturada en el titular satírico de "The Onion":
"CNN se reúne por la mañana para decidir
de qué deberemos sentir pánico durante el día".
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Las noticias son sobre cosas que ocurren, no cosas que no pasan.
Nunca ven un periodista que diga:
"Estoy transmitiendo en vivo desde un país que estuvo en paz durante 40 años",
o una ciudad que no ha sido atacada por los terroristas.
Además, las cosas malas suelen ocurrir rápidamente,
pero las cosas buenas no se construyen en un día.
Los periódicos podrían destacar:
"137 000 personas escaparon ayer de la extrema pobreza",
cada día durante los últimos 25 años.
Eso es 1250 millones de personas que dejaron atrás la pobreza,
pero nunca leen sobre eso.
Además, las noticias capitalizan nuestro interés mórbido
en lo que puede ir mal,
capturado en la política de programación: "Si sangra, manda".
Si combinamos nuestros sesgos cognitivos con la naturaleza de las noticias,
podemos ver por qué el mundo está por terminar
ya desde hace mucho tiempo.
Hay algunas preguntas sobre el progreso
que sin duda se les han ocurrido a muchos de Uds.
Primero, ¿no es bueno ser pesimista
para protegerse de la autocomplacencia,
para exponer la corrupción y decir la verdad al poder?
Bueno, no exactamente.
Es bueno ser preciso.
Debemos tener en cuenta el sufrimiento y el peligro
donde sea que ocurran,
pero también debemos ser conscientes de cómo se pueden reducir,
porque el pesimismo indiscriminado tiene sus peligros.
Uno de ellos es el fatalismo.
Si nuestros esfuerzos para mejorar el mundo
han sido en vano,
¿por qué seguir malgastando el dinero?
Siempre habrá pobres.
Y como el mundo terminará pronto
--si no nos mata el cambio climático,
lo hará la desbocada inteligencia artificial--
la respuesta natural es disfrutar de la vida mientras podamos,
beber, comer y divertirse, porque mañana moriremos.
El otro peligro del pesimismo irreflexivo es el radicalismo.
Si nuestras instituciones están fallando y sin esperanza de ser reformadas,
la respuesta natural es buscar destruir la máquina,
drenar el pantano,
quemar el imperio hasta los cimientos
con la esperanza de que sea lo que sea que surja de las cenizas
será mejor de lo que tenemos ahora.
Bien, si existe el progreso,
¿qué lo causa?
El progreso no es una fuerza mística o una dialéctica que nos eleva más alto.
No es un misterioso arco de la historia que se inclina hacia la justicia.
Es el resultado del esfuerzo humano gobernado por una idea,
una idea que asociamos con la Ilustración del siglo XVIII,
concretamente, que si aplicamos la razón y la ciencia
para mejorar el bienestar humano,
podemos tener éxito gradualmente.
¿Es inevitable el progreso? Por supuesto que no.
El progreso no implica que todo se vuelve mejor
para todos, en todas partes, todo el tiempo.
Eso sería un milagro, y el progreso no es un milagro
sino resolver problemas.
Los problemas son inevitables
y las soluciones crean nuevos problemas que a su vez deberán ser resueltos.
Los problemas sin resolver que el mundo enfrenta hoy en día son gigantescos,
incluyendo los riesgos del cambio climático
y la guerra nuclear,
pero debemos verlos como problemas a resolver,
no como apocalipsis en espera,
y buscar agresivamente soluciones
como la "descarbonización" profunda para el cambio climático
y el "cero global" para la guerra nuclear.
Finalmente, la Ilustración, ¿va en contra de la naturaleza humana?
Esta es una pregunta profunda para mí,
porque soy un gran defensor de la existencia de la naturaleza humana,
con todos sus defectos y perversiones.
En mi libro "La tabla rasa",
planteé que el panorama humano es más trágico que utópico
y que no somos polvo de estrellas, no somos de oro
y no hay forma de que volvamos al jardín.
(Risas)
Pero mi visión del mundo se ha relajado
durante los 15 años desde la publicación de "La tabla rasa".
Mi familiarización con las estadísticas del progreso humano,
comenzando con la violencia
pero ahora abarcando los demás aspectos de nuestro bienestar,
ha fortificado mi creencia
de que para entender nuestras tribulaciones y sufrimientos,
el problema es la naturaleza humana,
pero esta naturaleza, canalizada por las normas e instituciones de la Ilustración,
es también la solución.
Ciertamente, no es fácil reproducir mi revelación basada en los datos
con la humanidad en general.
Algunos intelectuales respondieron
con furia a mi libro "En defensa de la Ilustración",
diciendo primero, cómo se atreve a afirmar que los intelectuales odian el progreso,
y segundo, cómo se atreve a afirmar que ha habido progreso.
(Risas)
Otros, en cambio, son fríos con la idea del progreso.
¿Salvar la vida de miles de millones,
erradicar la enfermedad, alimentar a los hambrientos,
enseñar a leer a los niños?
Aburrido.
Al mismo tiempo, la respuesta más común que recibí de los lectores es gratitud,
gratitud por cambiar su visión del mundo
desde un fatalismo entumecido e impotente
a algo más constructivo,
incluso heroico.
Creo que los ideales de la Ilustración
pueden emitir una narrativa conmovedora,
y espero que la gente con mayor destello artístico
y poder retórico que yo
puedan contarlo mejor y esparcirlo más.
Es algo como esto.
Nacemos en un universo despiadado,
enfrentando el orden que posibilita la vida con gran dificultad
y en riesgo constante de derrumbarse.
Fuimos formados por un proceso despiadadamente competitivo.
Estamos hechos de madera torcida,
vulnerable a las ilusiones, el egocentrismo
y a veces a la estupidez asombrosa.
Pero la naturaleza humana también fue bendecida con recursos
que abren un espacio a un tipo de redención.
Estamos dotados del poder de combinar ideas recursivamente,
de tener pensamientos sobre nuestros pensamientos.
Tenemos un instinto para el lenguaje,
lo que nos permite compartir los frutos de nuestro ingenio y experiencia.
Nos hacemos más profundos con la capacidad de solidaridad,
de piedad, de imaginación, de compasión, de conmiseración.
Estas dotes han encontrado el modo de magnificar su propio poder.
El alcance del lenguaje ha sido aumentado
por la palabra escrita, impresa y electrónica.
Nuestro círculo de solidaridad se ha expandido
mediante la historia, el periodismo y las artes narrativas.
Y nuestras facultades racionales han sido multiplicadas
por las normas y las instituciones de la razón,
la curiosidad intelectual, el debate abierto,
el escepticismo sobre la autoridad y el dogma,
y la carga de la prueba para verificar las ideas
confrontándolas con la realidad.
Y la espiral de la mejora recursiva
cobra impulso,
ganamos nuestras victorias contra las fuerzas que nos oprimen,
sobre todo, las partes más oscuras de nuestra naturaleza.
Penetramos los misterios del cosmos, incluyendo la vida y la mente.
Vivimos más, sufrimos menos, aprendemos más,
somos más listos y disfrutamos más de los pequeños placeres,
y de las ricas experiencias.
Menos de nosotros somos asesinados, atacados, esclavizados, explotados
u oprimidos por los otros.
Partiendo de unos pocos oasis, los lugares con paz y prosperidad están creciendo
y podrían abarcar el mundo algún día.
Todavía queda mucho sufrimiento
y un tremendo peligro,
pero se han expresado ideas para reducirlos,
y se están concibiendo una infinidad de otras ideas.
Nunca tendremos un mundo perfecto,
y sería peligroso buscar uno.
Pero no hay un límite para las mejoras posibles
si seguimos aplicando el conocimiento para impulsar el florecimiento humano.
Esta historia heroica no es otro mito.
Los mitos son ficciones, pero esta es verdadera,
verdadera a nuestro mejor entender, que es la única verdad que podemos tener.
Cuanto más aprendemos,
podemos mostrar qué partes de la historia siguen siendo verdaderas y cuáles no,
cómo podrían ser algunas de ellas y en qué se podrían convertir.
Y esta historia no pertenece a una tribu
sino a toda la humanidad,
a cualquier ser sensible con poder de razonamiento
y la necesidad de persistir en su existencia,
ya que requiere solo las convicciones
de que la vida es mejor que la muerte,
la salud es mejor que la enfermedad,
la abundancia es mejor que la falta,
la libertad es mejor que la coerción,
la felicidad es mejor que el sufrimiento,
y el conocimiento es mejor que la ignorancia y la superstición.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)